mexican chilies used in sriracha
italian risotto rice
american corn that's used in just about
everything these staple crops are all
vulnerable to hot weather and a lack of
water and as many countries have been
hit by extreme droughts this year
farmers are feeling the heat as yields
are a fraction of normal levels italian
rice farmers for example are expected to
lose 30 to 50 percent of their yields
this year as paddy fields dry up
when you have this hot weather and
drought this late year it really puts a
lot of stress on those plans to really
keep time in their growth and that's why
some economists think that the crop
yield could be stressed and the yields
could go down
and commodities analysts say that those
lower yields could increase prices the
string of droughts coupled with food and
energy shortages and supply chain
disruptions are expected to keep the
cost of staples high this winter
waterways that typically feed the
agricultural systems across the world
have been parched by drought this summer
italy's longest river the river po
accounts for up to forty percent of the
country's agricultural production by
market value but water levels have
dropped well below normal in recent
months
in france the country has faced the most
severe drought ever recorded and during
china's driest summer in six decades
water levels plummeted in parts of the
yangtze river a crucial life source for
crops
in the u.s nearly 30 percent of corn
production is based in drought-hit areas
as record high temperatures have stifled
parts of north america it's been hot and
hotter than normal and
i think one of the key things to
remember
about the heat while it's been bad in a
lot of places it's exacerbating some
drought that was in existing parts of
the u.s when you put that hot weather on
top of the drought that's what's really
kind of the key thing here it's the
drought and the heat wave that has just
been
so bad this summer and it's put a lot of
stress on farmers our yields are off our
yields are probably off 25 percent a lot
of ranchers are having to
reduce or liquidate their herds all
these things
compounding could just
be a decision for a farmer to have to
call it quits drought affect the
price is fast let's say at local level
so let's say for tomatoes that are
produced i know in here in italy so they
will be more expensive if they
they have a let's say a reduction in the
production
but then
in europe but also global level we have
this interconnection in the markets and
for this we look mainly to the breadback
baskets that are the countries that
produce most grain south america
central us
ukraine
india also china when a drought hits one
or more of these so called bread baskets
there's less supply of staple crops in
the global market and as a result prices
get pushed up
this has happened before during drought
years like 2012 and while prices are
currently lower than they were during
march 2022 they are still historically
high and are projected to go up even
further in the months ahead
wheat prices are expected to jump by 20
to 30 percent this year according to
research by jp morgan
those changes and costs felt by
customers are being driven not only by
drought but also by the war in ukraine
and continued pandemic-related supply
chain disruptions but analysts say the
changing weather patterns we're seeing
this year will continue to influence key
agricultural markets well beyond this
summer scientists have forecasted there
will be an uptick in frequency and
severity of droughts as temperatures
continue to rise and that means
economies are going to have to brace
themselves as droughts can threaten
global food security
you